good morning Hank it's Sunday and today
we're going to talk about TV for
chickens which by the way would be a
great name for a band
Hank when the Eddie and I first started
dating I used to go to all these
contemporary art shows and I knew
nothing about contemporary art and the
art would be like a lady sitting in a
corner licking her own feet and I would
be like that is so interesting
well of course on the inside I was
thinking oh my god how many of these
things do I have to go to before this
girl let me take her on regular dates
like to dinners and movies in to other
places where people don't lick their
toes in public and in fact in today's
cultural discourse it's pretty normal to
think that contemporary art is stupid
but anyway it turns out that while I
still don't like toe licking in the
corner board for that matter toe wicking
anywhere there is in fact a lot of good
and interesting contemporary art which
brings me to this artist Sara's working
with named Thao Maki PAH who's finished
but lives in Germany and is doing an
exhibition here in Indiana and I've
become obsessed with this project that
Tam occupies did a few years ago in
which she created TV for chickens
so Thao monkeypod goes into this huge
hen farm where these chickens have like
absolutely no personal space and they've
literally never seen the light of day
because the farm is kept so dark to try
to keep the chickens calm and she shows
these thousands of chickens who have
lived their entire lives in the dark
this television show the chicken show is
just about chickens who do chicken stuff
like they're outside and they walk
around and they peck at the ground and
etc so Hank now you may be thinking
that's dumb I hate that why would we
make TV for chickens when we could draw
pretty pictures of starry starry nights
turns out the chickens who have lived
their whole lives in the dark and have
no idea what it's like to run free frack
and love the chicken TV show
it makes the chickens less anxious it
makes them peck at themselves less and
it makes them much less likely to commit
murder
not murder of humans but murder of other
chickens apparently homicidal chickens
are a huge problem in chicken farms so
basically TV for chickens makes chickens
more passive it makes them more likely
to accept their crap lives
I wonder what TV for humans does I mean
Hank now whenever I see people in
YouTube comments being giant squids of
anger like wow I always want to say dude
you need to watch more TV it'll wash
that homicidal aggression right off you
also you begin to think that if chickens
need TV for chickens in order not to
kill each other during their darken
miserable lives maybe I shouldn't eat so
many eggs
but even that response is inadequately
complex because the fact of the matter
is that if we all stopped eating eggs
and chickens chickens would go extinct
we've bred out all the natural defenses
of chickens the only reason the species
exists is because it's delicious
so TV for chickens which may have
initially not seemed like a great art
piece turns out to ask all kinds of
interesting questions so Hank
nerdfighters this is my non rhetorical
question for you
which is better a world where chickens
require TV for chickens in order not to
be driven into homicidal psychosis or a
world with no chickens at all Hank you
will see me tomorrow announcing several
exciting things including the winners of
the Paper Towns paperbacks
[Music]
so Hank right before I came downstairs
to film the video I asked the Yeti if I
should unbutton my second button in an
attempt to you know like bring a little
sex appeal to nerdfighteria and she was
like sweetie you know I love you but
you're just not a two buttons kind of
guy